toutes les femmes ont dit comment savait
était important d'être entendu d'abord
pouvoir dit évidemment parce que c'est
se libérer d'un lourd fardeau
ensuite elles ont été entendues elles
ont été cru se marier être cru cru enfin
et puis chacune d'entre elles ont
réalisé que j'avais d'autres femmes qui
avaient subi des abus sexuels
elle n'était pas seule ça permettait de
sortir de l'isolément parce qu'avec des
femmes d'autres communautés d'autres
nations qui avait subi la même chance au
delà de l' isolement ça permettait aussi
d'outrepasser la honte qui a été une
chape de plomb serait le pendant des
années il ya un phénomène d'un parent
même qu'on a vécu de nomen
d'autonomisation on dit en français
c'est à dire que pour certaines d'entre
elles il ya des enquêtes policières qui
ont été déclenchées qui sont pas
terminées dans d'autres cas n'ont qu'un
temps d'une anthologie policière est
encore dans un autre cas verdict de
culpabilité un emprisonnement
alors deux victimes elles sont passées à
survivante
elles se sont reconstruites dignité et
elles sont effectivement des modèles de
résilience